[Music]
jake is with us in saint louis jake
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey ken how you doing better
than we deserve brother how can we help
had a quick question so i i've been
teaching leading fpu and i just actually
just finished financial coach master
training and
i've been
telling people for years about
heloc's and stuff that they've been that
are just a you know credit card attached
to your house exactly um but i had a
quick question we were my wife and i
were walking in our neighborhood and one
of our neighbors told us hey i was
looking to move but
housing markets crazy and my banker told
me i have 70 000 of equity so he i don't
he did a cash out refinance or whatever
but
was doing instead of buying a new home
he was upgrading his home and i guess my
question is is what is the difference
between doing that as long as you're
doing it to actually upgrade your home
and just buying a new home and financing
all that stuff already in the home
well
the biggest thing is is these are
repairs or updates you should have been
doing all along
and so they don't come at you at 70 000
in one bill
and if you can do them seventy thousand
dollars in one bill you can do them in
phases
and you can cash flow
and then you don't need to add the debt
um obviously you know from coach master
training that even with a mortgage we're
gonna teach you to get out of the
mortgage
so we don't want you every time you want
a nicer home to move up in home or to
renovate your home either one we want
you to pay cash for doing either one of
those things because ultimately we want
to end up being 100 debt free so
i would reframe the approach and say um
instead of let's figuring out a time
that debt is okay let's figure i always
figure out a way to avoid it
and just not even ask the question is my
point um so i mean your neighbor didn't
ask you for coaching or me
and so but had they asked me for 70 000
bucks i i'm gonna guess and say he
probably could have cash flowed that in
24 months or maybe 36 months and done it
in three projects because it's probably
not just one thing
and um
if it is a 70 000 single improvement
that's highly unusual
highly unusual now you could do a 200
000 addition to a property and that
would not be unusual uh in that case i
just move personally
uh in almost every case and you hear me
say that all the time but even when you
move you're moving into a better
property you're going further into debt
now you got to turn around and reverse
the process again and start getting out
of debt again
and so i'm always trying to figure out a
way to to stop
the borrowing
not figuring out a way that it's okay
wonder what conditions is the borrowing
okay
instead of going that way it's always
figure out a way to stop the borrowing
because see what i did jake as you know
is when i went broke i vow i never
borrow money again
and so this is not an option for me if i
want to upgrade my house i want to move
up in-house i want to fix something in
my house there's only one method i can
use
because i'm never going in that again
it's only one method i can use i have to
pay cash
where nowadays we got more zeros on some
of our projects we're building a
conference center on top of the hill
here right above this building
uh that's about 40 million dollars
uh we're about
halfway through it a little more than
halfway through it um i'm at about 26
million in right now
and uh we got about a year left so that
tells me i got about 2 million bucks a
month to cash flow this puppy out the
door and we're watching it cash on cash
cash on cash cash on cash and i'm from
antioch tennessee i don't know where you
came from guys but that's a lot of money
to me that still freaks me out you start
talking about two million dollars for
something you start talking about two
million dollars a month for something
that just blows my little country mind
i'll tell you but that's what god has
said we're able to do we have the money
he's showing us to do it we're doing it
and we're going to help a lot of people
with that conference center and that's a
tool and what we're doing with it it's
not something i'm buying for personal
consumption
so
you know so again if i want a conference
center
i got to rent one
i got to use something around here and
stack chairs too high
we have to have cubicles that are two
stories or something in here uh until we
can afford to do a different building a
better building because we just don't
borrow money we just took it you know
anthony o'neil used to say it well when
he was here as a ramsey personality you
have to take debt off the table
i never said it that way before him but
it's a good it's a good way to remember
just take debt off the table so my point
is jake not is it okay you're probably
gonna be okay
but we're not trying to get to okay
we're trying to quit borrowing money
that's the new framework on it
so how can we do this and not borrow
money
or maybe we don't do it at all if we can